you
you
you
severa Cobian and I'm here with st.
Louis chess club and we're gonna play
the people for the next are in half so
if you want to play me just you can send
me a challenge I will see here so let's
see I will start with one game I think I
have one challenger already so let's see
two challengers I have I would maybe
prefer a little bit longer games if we
can start with or maybe three plus two
would be the ideal so so we can maybe do
three plus two time control so so I will
start with this game so I'm playing a
2100 and so this probably gonna be a
tough match here so let's see I have six
so we have the nimzo-indian defense and
I would prefer to play with increment
going forward just to avoid you know
flagging and a play on on time you know
castle
so I can enjoy India and the main idea
is to control the e4 score and that's
what I'm doing trying to do with the
night only four and now I will put the
night on d7 and try to organize an
attack on a light squares so we'll see
if I can manage to do that my opponent
is playing some aggressive moves so
let's see what is he planning to do now
with this h4 so let's see so h5 he plays
now I will just put the pawn on h6 to to
see what the ponent is trying to do some
Queen g5 ideas coming in putting
pressure on h5 and also attacking the g2
pawn so so he retreated to defend so
let's see here I feel like I might have
something here he's playing bit my
opponent playing bit dubious I think so
alright I'll just try to build up now I
want to put a knight on g4 putting
pressure on f2 so and he can still play
Knight g6 because 96 I'm gonna take on
g2 so I'll continue with the plum
getting my Knight to g4 now I'm putting
pressure on f2 so let's see what's gonna
happen now 20 for Bishop takes e4
attacking the Queen now h5 pawn is
hanging it feels like white position is
collapsing soon so let's see here ok I
will try to do this perhaps now I just
want to take on h5 with a Knight f3 ok I
retreat you here just keeping the eye on
keeping the eye on a4 ok my opponent is
not sure what is it trying to do so
let's see here let's take here threating
93 now guys trying to fork so we take
maybe one time here open up the position
of the King and say maybe put a rock on
d8 I'm thinking okay I'm up a pawn a
little bit behind on the clock so a
little faster now
sorry castle we put the night on g3 now
hitting the rook and hitting the knight
Knight is trapped in the corner guys
that's the reason why you don't put the
knight on the rim right knight on the
rim is dim and now the knight got
trapped and looks like the game is gonna
be over shortly Queen takes h4 followed
up with Queen takes h1 mate oh okay
all right excellent well prefer time
control probably would be like something
like three plus two we can play three
plus two that's probably the preferred
time control and I won my first game
guys so yeah this was the names of
Indian defense and yeah I think things
went till they're wrong so let's take a
look now okay so I have a lot of
challenges again I prefer that with
increments I can talk to you guys and
maybe explain to you what I'm trying to
do okay so let's see here so we have you
know accept the challenge from Nazgul
let's see now school 1700 all right good
luck
so I'm block again here so I will play
Knight f6 now I will play some tricky
line with okay let play it one more name
is o so now I play b6 putting the bishop
on putting the bishop on b7 so now I pin
first because if I think there should be
seven then there might be some a3 idea
so I don't want to allow that so I go
here there should be seven again I would
play this a little bit more aggressive
move it's probably not the best line but
I could to try this so let's see
ninety-four putting pressure
mm-hmm
so I take castle I'm already happy with
my position I am my opponent I think
didn't play the best way and okay wants
to get this c5 in it really wants to do
that and it's not really a big deal but
okay at least he's playing he's playing
dramatic here with this c5 so I expect
him to play c5 here because if it
doesn't play c5 then I just put a knight
on these seven it's gonna be difficult
so he didn't play that so let's see now
what can I do so I'm gonna put this
bishop here picks up c6 to put some
pressure on a 4 a 4 is a really really
weak pawn and now look how I do this
guys we take this way take and we play
d5 this way we lock the bishop okay we
shut down the bishop and now he's trying
to curse so now we get the knight active
here on a6 now we got the B 4 square for
the knight now we take back with the
Queen threatening checkmate on g2 so and
he blunders the mate so that's a good
game right there my opponent didn't pay
attention to the threat and that's why
when you have the bishop on c6 you have
a battery and he just my opponent didn't
see it so that was a quick win another
win with the name is oh let's see hey
hey guys see a lot of people in a chat
here 3 +2 probably would be the best
time control
well you just send the challenge to st.
Louis chess club account and that's
that's what you got to do
just send the challenge what do you
think of the proposed - winner of the
fdhs I'm not sure I'm familiar with yeah
this is a master class yes it's a blitz
session and a master class where I will
explain to you guys how to play blitz
properly and I've been playing blitz
since I was six years old and I played
with a lot of great great players Levon
Aronian I grew up with him Gabrielle
sardis is a very top player so I played
a lot of lot of blitz in my career I
always enjoyed the blitz in 2017 world
blitz championship I played against
Magnus Carlsen in a world of blitz
championship I played many many top
teams so let's is always fun and
enjoyable and so I will be a Grand
Master in resident at the Chess Club
next two weeks or so before I head out
for my tournament in Isle of Man feed
aground Swiss tournament and so I will
be doing some videos and this videos
will be recorded and uploaded I know you
guys waiting for those videos and so I
read your comments and appreciate the
support okay so stay tuned on the
channel on a st. Louis chess club
channel and tonight I'll be recording
some videos as well a Thursday night and
also Sunday so there should be some
fresh videos coming up all right so
let's move forward now next challenge
here we have all right 2100 let's see
here scar local all right so I play
let's see if my opponent wants to go
into the French so know you didn't want
to play the French so I go night have
six guys
okay I go be six again in the name zone
in the end you just put the bishop on b7
you control the e4 square okay so it's
very important you control the e4 square
there
castle I will play 76
yeah yeah the point of h3 is guys so
when I play Knight h5 my plane can go
Bishop h2 so that's the idea of the move
all right so now I need to come up with
a plan okay a6 just to cover the b v
square and i will just try to trade some
pieces and we had another strong chess
tournament at the chess club that i
finished yesterday Fall Classic
Tournament I don't know if you guys had
a chance to follow there are always
tournaments at the club and this was a
strong ten player round-robin tournament
and this was my first tournament after
the US Championship and in the last five
months
so and I finished strong winning the
last two games and tie for second place
in that tournament so the finish was
good there so you can check out some of
the games guys if you go to u.s. chess
champs and click on a PDF all open
you'll be able to see the CD games the
tournament was won by Ray Robson he had
a great run so Knight f6 now I want to
put the knight on e4 just the standard
stuff here nothing nothing special so
far just as you can see in all the games
I'm trying to fight for the e4 square
here so now Knight goes to e4 and let's
see not only for yeah it's very
important tonight to go on e4 and yeah
thank you for the compliment about my
videos I appreciate that Marcus okay so
the question is if I should start to go
really aggressive here so let's try it
it's a blitz game so we're gonna go
really aggressive now g5 h5 threatening
to play g4 yeah when you play these
positions guys putting the night only
four is the key okay I probably wouldn't
have played like this if this was a
longer game because White has a very
good move here so I'm not sure if my
opponent is listening so yeah
d5 would have been very strong if he had
played d5 I think I would have been in
serious trouble there so I will play
take yeah this is bit ultra ultra
aggressive here I'm not sure if this is
the right way to play in this position
but it's a blitz game my opponent has
one minute on a clock so I'm simply
going to just play natural moves open up
to h-file and hopefully try to give a
checkmate so I have some King g7 rotate
ideas double up the rooks triple up on
the H file and game is over okay
yeah 58 seconds a really tough situation
for my opponent to be I have a lot of
space I have a lot of space there and
now d5 he played it that's a correct
move actually I will play Queen f6 and
again my long-term plan here guys is to
play double up my rooks or okay and
Queen on H file and give a mate so it's
a very very difficult position for my
opponent there all right
Thank You Boris I I speak Russian and I
can read your comment appreciate that
and just challenge the st. Louis account
on on the leeches I already have 27
challenges so it looks like you know
we're doing good we got a lot of people
watching us and people are excited to
play me which is great so okay guys my
opponent is 20 seconds he's got a strong
idea Bishop c4 this is a good movie
played c5 this was a really good move so
for example if you're not paying
attention you take on c5 here with Detex
see if I'll be a blunder in plays Bishop
c4 and you're losing your queen so you
got to always pay attention to what's
going on on the board you can't just
play them without paying attention so
I'm gonna try to stop that idea but
here's the thing c6 I gotta tell you
it's not so easy I think I might have
miss played a little bit here but
luckily he doesn't have so much time so
maybe I can still create some ideas so I
still have a lot of activities and a lot
of ideas so c6 I go Bishop c8 and e4 not
sure what is trying to do so I could
have taken a rook actually but okay this
is good two three three and that's
that's not good that's that's not a
bish punish two guys that that's that
bishop is not going to be able to come
up so now the question is what's the
best way to win this guy's and we were
talking about putting them you know
doubling up so I'll just go King g7 with
what a very simple idea I just want to
play rook h8 so my opponent gives gives
us giving a pawn I'm not sure what is it
doing but I could take maybe I could
take perhaps or I could just try to go
for a mate immediately let's try to mate
immediately I believe this should be a
maid here you can get one more check on
c3 but after Bishop f6 the Queen is
hanging and made on h2 so that's game
over guys and yeah good game so let's
see if we have some more questions yes I
I got invited I got invited actually
yesterday to compete in a chess banter
championship and I'm excited about it
I'm not sure if they have the date
already been I looked at it and it's
gonna be 128 player knockout tournament
and it looks like it's gonna be like
something similar where we doing we're
gonna play people and we're gonna do
commentary and talk about the game int
so and I saw the list and Magnus Carlsen
is gonna be plain that tournaments the
chest 24 bumper blitz Cup and with some
really good prizes there so yeah I'm
looking forward to play that when they
announced the dates and let's see yeah D
if I would have blocked the bishop
yeah why try to create contra play but
it was not enough greetings Saint Louis
and I want to say hello to my Armenian
friends Karan my car to me on Mario's
and we have some good Russian friends
also commenting Boris trosman
let's see what stylish Thank You AP for
the compliment and alright let's play
another game now let's see we have guys
we have 39 people challenging I mean
this is 39 this is a record I believe a
friend of mine who works on a show Danny
Machuca and he mentioned that this might
be a record we have 38 so if we play
everybody I think that's gonna that's
gonna conclude I don't think we can play
okay so let's see here is the challenge
on the top is means that's the first
challenge Danny okay so the first one
have been waiting longer okay i'm gonna
accept the challenge by a guy a guy am i
always black or this is just the
settings okay no III mean I don't mind
playing black I'm just just just
wondering because all my games I'm
blocked okay I guess I can just play
block today guys it's it's it's okay
okay exchange violation I had exchange
violation in my penultimate round we got
this 93 Bishop before violation against
Grandmaster bortnik in a round eight of
the fee default classic so you guys can
check out that game it was disposition
and I managed to win that game with my
probably my best game of the tournament
it was a pretty clean game here so okay
my opponent is not sure what he's doing
so let's question the bishop here let's
see if he wants to give us the bishop so
in general guys you don't want to spend
two moves and give up the bishop here so
this is already a slight inaccuracy
because now I'm enjoying the pair of the
bishops and I'm not gonna give the pair
back I'm gonna try to keep the bishops
okay because having the pair of the
bishop is an advantage so that's why I
would like to keep it so 95
okay what's going on here
can we take on d4 I'm not sure let's
take it then mm-hmm
looks like we're up upon I don't think
yeah I don't think my opponent played
very accurately this all right so what's
going on here so we go Bishop to b6 so
the question is where is the
compensation is there a compensation
maybe there is I don't know so let's
find out
so it's tacking my knight all right
let's just try to trade some pieces now
so we're just trying to get rid of the
g5 night take when you're playing blitz
you don't need to like do too many
complicated things you just try to put
the pieces on natural squares
try not to calculate too many long lines
just you know play simple good moves
that's that's the key simple good moves
so here I'm trying to fight for the dark
squares with d4 so now I see five okay I
think I'm just up upon here guys so I
don't think I see any any compensation
here and generally Bishop is better than
knight in this kind of positions okay
because now I can put it on a long
diagonal and now I want to play some
maybe Queen g5 ideas as well so let's
see if you have Queen g5 let's see what
he will do we question the night we
question the night and then the next
thing would be to our what's happening
here I think my opponent blunder a
tactic do you see the tactic guys
alright let's do it
Bishop takes f3 take an advantage of the
pin piece that's the reason I play Queen
g5 attacking the knight and hoping that
he might play the Queen on d2 to protect
the night that way and then that will
allow Beatrice and this is not really
bad now because his light scores are
just terribly weak and once I put my
queen and a bishop queen first and then
Bishop behind it on that diagonal it's
gonna be some very serious consequences
here so Bishop there Bishop comes back
to now okay I just put it on I just put
it on aah
just put it on eight
my goal is to go Queenie 5:24 and that
should be good okay I have a problem was
on a background so I will make this
useful move to get a lift okay remember
your escape square and now up to Pansear
guys so this is just looking really good
looking really really good
and now I'm gonna go Queenie five Queen
a 524 and okay so what's happening here
Queen
alright guys should we try to he's
attacking the a6 pawn should we try to
do something okay let's just let's just
defend the pawn if take we take back
with the Queen I actually want my Queen
to be back on c5 so I can play Queen c6
so this is a really really comfortable
position
Ruki trees and the works yeah always
keep your King protected you know try
not to get into positions where you have
to worry about the safety of your King
because in a blitz game it's very hard
to defend the King so you know you just
you don't want to spend time defending
so you want to have ideas so okay Luke
III is coming rook takes a three I can
win another pawn if I want I have Queen
c6 ideas as well so I don't know what's
what's happening here but it looks very
strong
and he blundered the queen so well
position was already hopeless and but on
top of that my opponent blundered the
Queen so let me see if I close sir here
so I can read read your comments here
my opponent resigned guys so greetings
from Russia
hello ceefor after he takes d5 yes you
can play the question is about playing
the exchange French and then c4 so you
could do that that's fine let's see a
nice pawn structure yeah I like the
knight g7 set up against the exchange
violation I prefer that more videos well
we're going to be making more videos
next two weeks guys the videos are made
when I'm working for the club as a
grandmaster in resident and that's when
these videos are recorded and uploaded
okay
okay let's see here h6 yeah well you
have to get your lift okay
alright guys so trying to read if
there's any interesting questions here
but yeah I'm you know I'm glad to see
everybody watching and tuning in for the
stream from Serbia from Czech Republic
from Denmark Brazil South Africa France
Sweden Wow yeah there are some nice
countries that I haven't been to so it's
on my list to visit one day guys so some
of the countries I haven't been to would
like to visit so guys we are up to 53
people challenging right now my goodness
53 people all right David we're gonna
challenge accept the David's challenge
he's been waiting and now I've got again
with white guys so I'm gonna show you
some d4 stuff now I'm gonna show you how
we attack with white now okay we block
we go a little bit defensive and then we
just try to take advantage of it so now
let's see what David is gonna play here
so David is playing a Kings Indian
defense so my last round game was very
similar to it wasn't exactly Kings
Indian but it was like similar structure
here so we play h3 because when we put
the bishop on a3 we don't want to be
bothered with Knight g4 and h3 also
stops the bishop HG for idea in general
it's a useful move for you to play this
okay now c5 now he's going into some
kind of benoni type of positions so I go
here so let's see now take take and okay
this is a critical moment here my
opponent can played a very sharp line
here or he can play positionally the
question is what would be the best thing
to do so he decided to play positionally
the other line would have been nice if
he had played b5 the nice sharp line
okay but he didn't do that so we play
castle and now it's a Ben only defense
and I like these positions quite a lot
for white I've I've had very good score
in this type of structures you know many
structures and feel feel pretty
comfortable playing them so not easy for
black to move because space there is
some space advantage problems so c4 is
an interesting attempt try to get the c5
screw for the night I'm gonna go Bishop
f4 again it's it's very unclear whether
or not this is actually gonna work you
know so let's see for him this before
and looks like my opponent is not quite
comfortable in a position because he's
spending a lot of time here and yeah
it's already not looking that great
okay let's see here okay Queen b6 I'm
not sure what my opponent is trying to
do so that's prepared if I break here
guys we're gonna prepare the break and a
few ways I can play here I can go Bishop
h2 but another idea like here is I like
to get rid of my opponent's dark square
bishop here so I mean again bish page 2
was completely fine but I want to put a
bishop on d4 so that's why I did this so
once I trade the dark square bishop then
I can organize a strong attack because
the King is gonna be vulnerable because
of ducks for bishops so this is pretty
standard to the next few moves maybe we
get rid of the bishop takes back and now
this is interesting so there's a lot of
opportunities here for me so I will play
Queen d2 now I want to try to get this
guy here guys now 95 is a huge threat so
essentially my opponent has only one
move here to stop the Nigeria and if he
doesn't play that move he is in very
serious trouble so and he find the right
move which I was expecting so night goes
on d4 now guys we're challenging the b
phi pawn and getting ready to play a 4
and i think my opponent just didn't see
it that i was attacking the pawn twice
so now i'm attacking it twice and takes
i take back with a knight the queen and
i just play an a4 this way i'm cementing
the position of the knight on a very
good square now he's trying to do
something like this and I'm just gonna
win the pawn
okay I could have played also Queen d2
and take with the Queen position is just
lost here so it doesn't really matter
I'm up two pounds here and opponent
doesn't really have essentially any any
serious compensation just yeah just have
to be careful not to blunder anything so
if you blunder something yeah then you
can't let the opponent come back into
the game but otherwise it's very
difficult okay now we take and
okay we can just trade everything and
just come back and up two pounds and
that should be a pretty straightforward
win so king h2 now the six pawn is under
attack as well yeah two extra ponents is
a very very serious advantage in a
position like this okay I don't have to
do this but I will
I really don't need to do this move it
actually weakens my position but I could
probably get away with it
alright so I'll do it anyway just just
to make it interesting I didn't have to
play it but it's probably not a bad move
I normally don't like to weaken position
on my king when I'm winning like this
because sometimes it could be costly but
here I think it should be okay so it
takes okay we take and now we have three
extra pawns
so do you extra pounds is quite a lot
I'll just play b3 protect everything and
h5 is played by my opponent I play g5
because now I have some Queen f6 ideas
if I want to so I mean now right away so
the question is now do we need to play
Queen f6 years and we're up three pounds
so I would say sure why not give up one
pawn and just you know go f4 next move
f4 it's important to get into to stop
the king and then king if King f3 King
before it's completely winning so that's
game over so let's take a look at the
chart here see what we have we have a
lot of friends watching left Levenberg
ramyon
wants to play hello laughs they were
Bishop c4 okay why not Bishop c4 bishops
before he will play Knight takes e4 in
that position and he takes the pawn on
e4 so I won't be substitute to protect
it here the the e pawn was hanging that
was the question then only the idea is
to give up on four activity well
sometimes they do give up pawn for
activity sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't so it's it's no guarantee okay
yes you relax only when opponent resigns
correct you never relax until opponent
stops the clock you know and ready to
you know shake hands okay that's only
only when the score sheets are signed
okay that's when you relax a lot of
players including myself and many we
make a mistake of thinking the game is
already over but it's not so let's see
we have people watching us all over the
world we have fans from India from Iraq
I mean we really got a lot of
international people watching all right
so let's see here guys we have we are
beating our record today 57 challengers
we have currently waiting look at this
list here so we have 3 plus 2 is the
time control we're playing today guys so
yeah we have huge huge lineup here guys
so we have one opponent I'm gonna wait
so we're gonna give a chance here a
happy pawn happy pawn
2200 so this is a serious opponent okay
so 2200 it's so it's so okay I play 93
sometimes but I'm gonna just play Knight
f3 now just to see it okay now check I
play an IBD to here
Quinn a four-track a three giving me
narration
all right so go here yeah this is
actually slightly better for white I
think because now I get the bishop on
with you it's not so clear what is this
Knight can do insist six the future of
this Knight is not very clear okay guys
the future of that night so I think with
this night Bishop takes is absolutely a
playable as well so he wants to play b5
so we're of course not gonna blunder
that we're gonna play Queen c2 and now I
go night ear takes Knight takes
okay yeah so my opponent is I'm actually
playing quite well I I I like how he's
playing here so definitely a strong
opponent it looks like so let's get the
bishop here bishops are always good guys
so we get a bishop it's good I don't
think I played the best way so far so
but we'll see Queenie aids very fast too
he's not only just playing good moves
playing fast them too you know all right
let's take the pawn here I hope
I'm not blundering something here b8
okay I have Queenie - actually okay I'm
not sure about my position here I think
my opponent has a lot of threats so I
might need to be careful here okay okay
I'm going to focus a little bit guys so
I can win this game hopefully otherwise
it's not so easy okay I can tell you
that it's not easy okay so so we're
gonna do this funny move here castle yes
it's still legal guys it's still legal
to castle okay there's a huge move
otherwise you know it's 39 h2 and stuff
wow what is this guy doing he's he's
like tactical guy wow I was that was a
strong tactic wait this guy is like 2200
he's playing really really strong
alright so let's see here
wow that was a strong tactic
this guy's must be a grandmaster or
something yeah this is a very strong
tactic 93 I missed this guy's Wow our
perfect record might be in trouble here
might be in danger now alright so
yeah this bishop chief island the way he
played it was amazing how quickly he saw
this idea all right
so what to do rook g1 Queen C six years
unfortunately yeah but I might yeah I
don't I don't have anything better
though this was wow this was a
world-class tactic seriously I mean this
was like amazing alright well guys we're
in trouble here so we might lose this
game okay I didn't play too well but but
he my opponent played well so that's
credit goes to him alright so yeah this
is not good we didn't play well he
played well so okay so he's not even all
right let's get rid of this acquaints
here I'm just trying to get some kind of
endgame you know but I don't know if I
can even get that yeah mmm not easy not
easy I can tell you it's not easy
well let's try this guy's last a try now
it's a very very difficult position yeah
looks like a good game yeah that was a
good game here let's quickly look at
this this was quite quite impressive
play actually by black so ok probably
probably this night see for maybe guys
wasn't the best I just maybe just got
carried away a little bit Bishop c4 and
just Castle was the normal way to play
so clearly taking with the night it's
like delaying a development little bit
but yeah and he played well if they're
very well here now I'm a little bit
behind in development here so it's not
so simple maybe I should just play
Bishop d3 and give up the pawn I don't
know if we can do the analysis you know
I don't think we should be three take on
g2 Orochi 1 and this should be 2 and
long Castle it's it's interesting so
anything well here I not sure if
well if I knew you out ACTA call dis
opponent was I woulda just trade Quincey
guys for sure this was quite impressive
he he played really strong tactical rook
takes b5 was not easy idea to do and
then take I mean and the 93 was very
nice tactic basically using the the
overworked piece the Queen is overworked
because if I take with a pawn now it's
hanging and the Queen takes is a Bishop
g5 threat and unfortunately I don't have
the move f4 because of the queen bee to
mate so perhaps maybe a long castle was
not correct but it's some problems
because he is threatening to play yeah
all right all right let's go we have
another game here yeah that was a tough
one guys that was a tough loss alright
okay let's see here we have another game
started here let's see if there is an
interesting questions okay guys let's
we're gonna focus on this game now so so
we have another King's Indian here
a ch3 now 96 comes in I will play d5 I
don't know if my opponent gonna play
he's gonna play back
I'm gonna take with this spawn here I
just want to play this position with the
epon you know okay rook e1
putting pressure Bishop g5 okay Quincy
it I'm not sure what is he trying to do
is he gonna really suck on h3 I mean
that's just that's just not gonna work
in my opinion but maybe he will all
right let's see that goes on d4 yeah he
does it so he wasn't kidding he just did
that but okay the SAC shouldn't work at
him with all the ideas this sac
shouldn't work
okay now okay
okay so what do we do all right let's
bring the rock in I always like to bring
all my pieces in so that way they're all
developed
and let's put a queen here for now
in 94 is coming up
of course if the night moves I will
trade quince and I'm pretty happy about
that
okay Quincy five okay I was expecting
this
so let's bring this Bishop back for a
second but I think some 96 ideas you
know
okay I'm going to try to trade a few
pieces
I will protect my position
take
yeah I don't think this the sacrifice
work do you know I don't think it does
work so let's try to trade you go for
attack actually but it's quite solid so
it's not gonna be easy to give a mate
now is threating some 9f2 ideas can we
defend
now we attacked Queen
yeah very good all right next let's see
here let's stay see if we have some
questions okay all right let's see what
we'll have we have some questions people
asking
okay
all right let's see guys more questions
we have
all right
yeah the HTS act didn't quite work so
the last player do HOF Kyle our minion
friend I think just it was very very ya
the sacrifice didn't quite work here
let's see let's see here hey it's
Benjamin hey Benjamin
greetings Benjamin from st. Louis yes
man Jimmy let's see who else is there
some friends that I know and students
okay guys all right okay I guess
let's see here I only play challenge
them in it yeah I see Benjamin yeah all
right very good guys so we have 53
people challenging us and we have about
25 minutes left so we'll get a couple of
more games in okay and two we'll be
doing this again next week I believe
next Thursday so make sure next Thursday
three o'clock your only chance if you
want to play me okay if you want to have
like discussion and we can talk about it
if here are some good questions you can
ask me okay okay
next person who has been waiting is a CC
& T let's see here
alright should we do some fun opening
let's see I go here
the ship g4 so we have some you know
it's a check perk the name of this
opening so
I gave up the to Bishop so probably
didn't play the best way but as long as
I can trade taxco bishops I'm happy
because then my opponent doesn't have
and here I want to trade Queens because
if I trade Queens
I can put my king on his seven and
hopefully I can play b5 so I have some
good pressure here you know on the Queen
side so I go King g7 b5
all right let's see here
they're London let's see ya guys I wish
I can play all of you but you know we
have so many people in line and I'm kind
of going by there you know by the people
who've been waiting the most you know so
but yeah so just make sure if for some
reason you know if you didn't get to
play today just try to be back next week
3 p.m. Central Time ok that's around the
time we are we gonna start the stream
and you know and I'll be happy to play
you ok
and also the I want to make sure you
guys watching the World Cup it's the
first three rounds already finished at
the World Cup and there's 16 players
left and it's quite exciting we got
three Americans in that 16 field they
got Jeffrey shank we got Wesley so in
linear Dominguez so we have three guys
in and if they can win a couple of more
matches just few more matches you know
and we could have you know more
representatives in the next candidate
tournament because the first two places
qualify to the candidate tournament so
make sure you tune in tomorrow and watch
and support you know if you're from us
our American players and see if they can
pull through and qualify we already have
Fabiano Caruana in it as a runner-up so
he'll be doing but Jeffrey's wrong yeah
he's he had a great match sensationally
defeated anna Shaqiri in a nice tactical
game the last playoff game and I was a
beautiful game he won and basically yeah
send give it home so he's playing a very
tough opponent
jean-christophe Duda next match and you
know it's do that it's a little bit
higher than Jeffrey but you know Jeffrey
is very young and talented so he can you
know I think he he has good chances
and to Wesley Wesley soils gonna be
playing with you go
and I believe Lanier Domingues is gonna
be playing Aleksandr Grisha
so those are going to be the big big
matchups
starting tomorrow okay I'm better here
but I need a plan so I'm gonna bring the
night to b6 and tried to fork and win
the a3 pawn this before mu bite have
been weakening so my opponent is behind
on a clock and it's a tough position to
be in so I'll just consolidate the
position with f6 maybe I should have
played Knight f6 actually I regret doing
that I let him off the hook a little bit
there but yeah probably shouldn't have
done that so I'm gonna take this one
I'm gonna go here so my plan is to get a
knight only six my plan is to get a
knight only six so let's see if I can do
that and my opponent plan is to get a
king on before all right so let's see
here
see if we can come up with some ideas
here let's
all right we're gonna we're gonna have
to play fast and put some pressure
yeah I don't think I'm playing the best
way to send [ __ ] but so I'd be it might
be a drill actually we I'm not happy the
way I play the same game so okay here
not quite happy the way I play this
now all we give a letter
I think I'm
probably winning in the king and pawning
game but I'm not sure he didn't take it
so okay this is interesting so take
take
if you like my kingís closer here guys
what do you think I should be able to
win
and
all right good game good game I was that
was that was a pretty pretty well played
game by my opponent I mean I was
slightly better but it was not easy all
right let's see here looking forward to
him and I wonder of course
yeah they're too bright you know
American you know they're live you know
the young American players have great
future some people think Duda is favor
it against young but then they think
they're gonna run into nvl so they think
LVL is gonna go through but wait did and
we all have to play the winner of
Aronian game do I have a classical chess
player yes of course I grew up studying
a lot of Karpov and Petrosyan games so I
studied their collection of the best
games by world champion petrosyan and
Karpov so let's see no no I mean it
stick our stream is in English but ok
you can type in Russian I can understand
that also or you can type in you know
you know we have some Armenian friends
who were typing so but yeah so let's see
here challenge me let's see how do you
come up with ideas in dynamic positions
well first thing you got to do is look
at the placement of your pieces see if
your pieces are well placed and if you
think they're not you can try to improve
the place pieces okay so that's
important alright so petrosyan okay I
grew up you know in Armenia and the
chess school I went to was named after
world champion petrosyan so I was you
know you know one way or another already
influenced influenced by his game
because I was from the same country that
he was a world champion and but also I
enjoy his games I think it was a very
unique sense for the positional play
here all right guys let's get one more
game in here
probably gonna get maybe two more let's
see
hi there people hide their people let's
see let's see alright let's play a
little French defense ich as you guys
know I'm a French player lifelong French
player had been playing this opening for
30 years and you know sometimes are
really good game sometimes I have some
bad games as well but you know it's a
kind of opening that you're gonna lose
games sometimes but you if you you know
study and play well and you're gonna get
rewarded as well you know so so I
actually had a game like this before
some quite familiar with this set up
yeah this is this is actually played
before this so the point is not to
castle then you play h6 and then setting
nipple play Dru cage 3 root g3 huh so
this was like an apple idea so so my
opponent I don't know if he knows this
game but he was just trying to lure me
into castle so he can play Bishop age 7
and win the game you know and 95 check
so he probably was trying to do
something like that but
okay so we're gonna start the track we
don't need to castle here King is
perfectly safe on a eight in fact it's
safer there then you cancel if you
castle
then opponent can go Queen III or Queen
d2 and sack on h6 and tack you so in
fact your king is much safer to be only
eight here okay so now I'm just trying
to play before an attack okay now he's
going back I'm not sure what is it
trying to do so we stick with a program
right we just play b5 to play before you
stay with the program
well yeah there's a good comment about
Petruchio being a tactical player but
yeah I mean Petrossian didn't attack
often but it was a it was it was a joke
that his colleagues made actually about
petrosyan they say Petrosyan doesn't
attack often you know but when he
attacks most likely you're done you're
gonna get made it okay so he wouldn't
attack often but when he attacked he
made sure he calculated very deeply
enough that his opponent is not gonna
survive the attack so he did obviously
have some nice attacking wins as well
you can't just become a world champion
by defending so Queen III okay I'm
trying to trap this knight in a corner
it's not so easy at least okay let's see
here okay can I go like
I probably could have played better now
I'm thinking I'm not sure if I like what
I did
okay I probably need to bring the screen
back to c7 here guys and then play like
night a seven-night b5 I think that's
gonna be a strong plan here hopefully I
don't get me it yeah yeah I was I was
worried I was worried about that move I
was little worried about that move and
he played it basically my opponent is
playing correctly he's creating a contra
play and I'm in trouble here this didn't
go that well this didn't go according to
the plan here
okay we take this guy
oh this is a good news guys we want to
central pawns and now we're fine yeah we
got lucky didn't play g6 you know I
don't know why he hesitated it a little
bit too long when you start an attack
you go for it
you cannot hesitate once you hesitate
you start doing other things since this
is just you're gonna lose the momentum
here okay we got to make sure we don't
blunder Queen f7 here okay so that
that's a key so let's put the bishop
here
okay is attacking here
I sure what's going on here it's it's
super messy I have many interesting
ideas
okay let's just go here
now I want to take on h4
now the night is under attack and 25
well it's a good shot
okay it's getting too messy it was just
straight Queens it's getting a bit too
messy here
things get really complicated you want
to trade the pieces oh we also have a
nice advantage on the clock which would
be useful in blitz you know the clock is
very very important so it's better to at
the worst position but more time on a
clock but if you have a really good
position you're very low in the clock
it's gonna be very hard in a blitz game
okay so not sure what is he trying to do
here so let's it's still a little
questioning and ask him where is he
gonna go now okay
let's ask him again where are you gonna
go now
with the rook the problem is also the
knight is actually hanging on h3 so okay
let's take this guy let's get back on
this diagonal
now pin it to win it
we want to pin him again
and end the game with a nice schecky
okay that should do it for this game
okay guys let's see if we have some more
interesting questions here all the kind
is the best of all time yeah I mean the
you know it depends on a preference guys
I mean so there it really depends on
your preference Bishop takes g5 check
yeah
Bishop c3 we should be v is winning okay
guys and let's see we still have a lot
of people waiting for the challenge okay
so we still have a lot of people so
let's see here alright so let's start
this game here I'm white in this game
and against the 2000 rated opponent so I
expect this would be a challenge
let me play this line see
see if my opponent knows this line
Tabish Petrie
yeah I played this in one of my games
this 92 is a very interesting move the
point is I want to play now Knight c4
hitting the Queen and yeah so he didn't
take so now what was the idea here
there's a way you know the couple of
games ended and drop tonight b3 queen
takes c3 and Bishop d2 so there were
there were a couple of games played like
that that ended ended in a draw so I
will just go Bishop e2 I think this is
the correct move see I hope I'm not
mixing this because if I mix this up
it's gonna be bad
all right I hope I'm not mixing but I'm
not hundred percent sure guys I only
played recently this 92 line so have
only one game so far played in it I
found it very interesting move but not
easy to play
okay let's castle let's get those safety
mm-hmm
and if he takes now I feel like I have
an IB 3 tactic which is which is huge
because otherwise my Center is just
collapsing so an IB 3 now actually I can
go Knight c4 I feel like it's better now
where is the Queen going big question is
where is the Queen gonna go and then I
go d5 I'm ready to give up my exchange
here for the initiative okay yeah this
is already clearly better for me because
I have the center and my opponent pieces
are very awkward here threatening in 96
now by the way guys
yay again we'll be back at 3 o'clock
next week okay
okay Queen d7 okay I'm not sure what's
going on here so let's just take this
for now Queen d2 I want to get rid of
the dark square bishop here as soon as
possible because I feel like if I do
that that they'll give me a nice
advantage so but first things first
gotta get your rooks together guys
always put your looks together remember
okay let's see if we can weaken the
position a little bit okay most likely
this is the last game guys because we
don't have that much time so I have d6
here takes Queen d6 takes takes that
winning exchange so if it takes I can
take I think it works yeah he never got
to finish his development so this is the
big problem for my opponent if he had
gotten his Bishop out and maybe you
could have been okay no but now it's
just problematic yeah we take there are
many ways you can play this position but
I'm just gonna play the most simple way
and just to create problems for my
opponent
yeah d6 pawn is very really advanced
quite deep in us it's difficult to do
much about it so I will play this Bishop
d5 there are other moves as well it's a
tactical idea if it takes on d6 I can
take on f7 so just using some tactical
ideas so now we go in troop belongs on a
7th right guys your rooks always belong
on a 7th rank
we develop
now look at this tactic guys fishkrap
seven check if takes with the rook we
take the Queen if takes with the king we
have Queen b6 so you had to go there
letter check and we pick up a bishop
not sure why I did that last move but
okay all right guys this was great okay
let's attend let's look at some we have
yet three p.m. next Thursday guys next
week okay my friend Eric Rosen is here
hey Eric so who else is here let's see
yeah we had a couple of friends that I
know as students I was thank you for
joining everybody 3 p.m. next Thursday
I'll be up again playing and you know
sorry if we didn't get to play you we
had a lot of people waiting and we still
have 37 people in a queue but we run out
of time time goes by quick when you're
playing blitz as you know so and again
thank you for joining everybody let's
see yeah rook 107 to always remember
rook on a seventh rank and that's how I
won this last game rook on a seven bish
25 and yeah once again thank everybody
for watching and tuning in and this was
a lot of fun and we'll be back here next
Thursday for some more stream and play
ok